hey guys how's it going welcome to the
first video in my summer snack series if
you're not sure what that is it's
basically seven days of summer snacks
today we're going to be making banana
popsicles and I chose banana because the
only color on Amazon that I saw that I
could get same-day was a yellow popsicle
stick mold you can also just use paper
cups and put some popsicle sticks in
them so we got this that's step 1 step 2
we're gonna need 2 medium bananas 1/2 a
cup of heavy cream
1/3 cup superfine sugar this looks fine
me 2 cops whole milk this is just really
organized okay so it says to mash the
bananas very well with a potato masher
do I look like I have a potato masher
well you know what I do have is a
blender and I'm gonna use it second like
you could probably easily do this and a
bowl but that's all we're doing here
this looks fairly medium right ok half
cup half cup that is really heavy two
cups of milk
and you go I know I'm not really about
that majoring life so I got these on
Amazon - I think I have an Amazon
addiction clear every size I'll need
come on third one third cup success now
my friends it's time to blend if these
they're all the great summer summer
popsicle banana snacks feel like you can
probably add other types of fruit in
here too if you want to add some
blueberries stupid lid just pops off
don't put it in the dishwasher they save
what am I do put it in the dishwasher
did I break it
oh no I think it's broken
my blender did you use it well no I just
did no see the thing was his blender
I just was asking if you've used it I
wasn't saying you did I think this is
the final demise
I'm not sure what happened but it's
working guys it's working this is great
I want to sleep with this thing through
actual hell so okay well it's working
cool um once you do this which you could
easily have done inside of a bowl you're
gonna put them in your little bowls our
nice little trace I like soup
I trust me I can't believe that this
thing still works and now you just put
it in here don't pull it too much up at
to the top because it will freeze over
just click one just like that just like
that these are gonna be so yummy
this is my first time making these so
I'm hoping for the best so now we just
need to put these in the freezer for two
to four hours two to three hours
basically just put them in the freezer
till they're frozen and I'll see you
guys then mmm
all right it's what you guys involve in
waiting for it's been more than two to
three hours since the popsicles have
been placed in the refrigerator freezer
I mean here they are real frozen looking
real beautiful taking G's out see if we
can get it out nope
run some hot water over it look at that
it looks so good now for the taste test
my teeth are sensitive oh I'm so cold
mmm this is a nice chaste I would offer
my sister some but she's allergic to
bananas seems to be an ongoing theme and
those cooking videos that I do i laughs
program well thank you guys so much for
watching the first episode of my summer
snack series it's gonna be a super fun
week so I'm really excited to make a
bunch of treats for you guys
treats drinks snacks I'm not really even
sure all the what I'm gonna make yet but
I hope you all love it I'll put a link
in the description to a playlist you can
follow along feel free to leave some
comments on what you think I'm gonna be
making tomorrow or even just some
suggestions on things that I should make
in the future I'll see you guys tomorrow
oh gosh so cold by piece